get out of here they gonna search every
street
like Mafia dons you don't get to choose
life you won't lose you wait away damn
girl here bill oh oh pimp
oh there's a look at her new movie pimp
and I'm sold they're pulling me in with
that trailer okay could we just
acknowledge this look was as good as
last night's look at the premiere they
loved it a hot pink do we love you we
were like dad we're like okay with the
high pony who saw you uh you know was
amazing before we get into the movie is
a premiere last night miss Sharon Stone
yeah that's the premiere oh my gosh she
was so dope and she was just showing me
so much love it was just so cool I'm
definitely a fan of hers and she's done
great work and ii used to do great work
so it was so cool for her to you know
come out and support like that did you
know she was gonna be there I had no
idea but you know what Christine told me
that great things yes you're dirty yeah
the director and her are great friends
and Christine told me she's one of the
first people she showed the film to and
just how supportive she'd been so it was
important that she was there tonight
well speaking of but films have we saw
the trailer for it girl it is so intense
we're so excited for it would you say
this has been one of your most
challenging roles so far absolutely
without a doubt you know it's I'm I'm
drawing of course from my personal
experiences as far as where I can find
the emotion but Wednesday as a
completely different person than I am
her life you know just her story but
what I love so much about playing this
character as I could I could humanize
them because so many people judge this
person on what they think and I think
this this movie does show a lot of
hearts absolutely it does feel or you
know just by looking at it it's a lot of
different than we're used to for me you
know it's like only 180 was that part of
the reason why you wanted to jump at
this part and at this movie absolutely
that's exactly why and also just
different images of women showing
different levels of strength and
vulnerability and just life lessons and
trying to remove generational curses
with that we all go through I really
want to show something different and
also let people know like I'm I'm not
somebody that's gonna be typecast
I love to play any range of problems
well you've always been such an epitome
of girl power and was that also a factor
you know joining the the film too
because you know it's about strong women
and you know it was directed by a woman
you know how important is that female
representation in Hollywood that was
very important to both Christine and I
with this project it's written and
directed by a female it's all about
female survival and the best way they
know how to survive where they're from
with the tools that they have and so for
me I think in life it's important that
we show these different images of women
we give women opportunity to show
different characters different attitudes
and it's not just one type or one look
what's the vibe like on set you know
because I know it's an intense feeling
but like you're fun but the Bible set
was fun but also intense because the
reality is we're playing characters that
live there live in a tough life you know
their life is that they find happiness
in their life you see these moments of
joy and the true love between Nikki and
Wednesday but the reality is a lot going
on and so you have to kind of always
carry that through you whatever project
you're doing you have to carry the
sentiment of it through the entire shoot
there was a quick shoot but during that
entire shoot I was carrying Wednesday's
weight on my shoulders well how did you
kind of take yourself out of that
character then take so difficult right
because that sticks with you you know
that the heaviness that you felt going
into that character so for me it was
important to do different work more fun
more comedy dive into my music once I
was done with that project some more and
that's really what they had to because
I'm like I can't go right back into a
deep intense one like this speaking how
music are we gonna get some new stuff
from you see yes I just dropped my
second single read read love you know I
had bossy that premiered on star on Fox
and that was awesome
and now I've better - I've loved in my
album will be coming out early next year
we can't wait that just keeps going all
right screen in my ears on the radio I
want to ask you about one of your
Instagram post recently you know you
defended Kanye's I love that music video
like the use of the word ho like I'm
like drawing parallels to the use of
pimp you know your anger don't talk to
me about that where art almost gets a
where you feel like they take the power
back
like what I think I think you can take
the word back on anything the same thing
with the B word same thing with n-word
you know depending on your culture and
your group I feel like you can take that
you could take back anything you want he
can mean whatever he wants to you and in
this song and though I thought it was
very satirical how they did it I
actually did feel like they were saying
look we're two guys the big suits you
know this these masculine guys but you
know it you are such a thing ho
apparently but I love it and what I got
from it was like you know what like
that's what they call you that's what
they think you are but you know I love
it I love that you're sexually free I
love you proud of who you are and you're
not afraid when you want to say about it
because that's how I feel yeah women
aren't just sexual creatures for men you
know we have our own thoughts our own
ones and feelings in charge the Kanye
gets a bad rap I think Kanye is an
individual he has his own opinions right
and everybody's not gonna always agree
with your opinions I think why he gets
such a bad rap is because you know as
african-american as a black person in
America you look to someone like Kanye
and you want them to be you know a
leader for you and so when when the
opinions are so different than what we
feel as a cultural group is it's
disappointing I think you know but
everybody is entitled to have their own
opinion so yeah and we need people like
that who have a huge problem like that
too
yeah I feel like he's an artist right
yes all of that is leaning towards that
stuff the stuff that we need which is
our yes just giving me a message if it's
making me feel something I'm going to
listen to it speaking of feeling
something we want to talk to you about a
couple of pop culture things including a
store Aegis album being named sexiest
man alive as you know this is final many
levels I just I love his work he's a
great business man he's handsome and he
seems like a cool guy I've never met him
but he seems really cool I think we need
to get you guys in the breaking down all
this the facts about I remember when he
did obsessed with Beyonce they literally
her name is Erin in the script and I
heard little bits of his accent he's
like char
I love it one of my favorite keke palmer
movies is in the oh my gosh hey guys
it's Thursday we're gonna throw it back
I mean do you get tired of people
drawing that connection I mean that was
such an amazing movie with Angela I
can't say that I get tired because the
reality is is it's been my life since I
did that movie I spent like two three
years after that that's what people you
know grew to really love and definitely
remember me for and what I like is that
it keeps me in people's hearts forever
you know because that movie I did as a
kid my fans that our children grew up
with that and then even adults and
parents they shared that with their kids
so I wouldn't say that gets tired of it
but I am excited to see what they think
when they see pimp Missy Elliott is
making history the rapper and become the
first female rapper to be nominated for
the Songwriters Hall of Fame yes
Kiki I gotta ask you first before we
play this game of finished the Lehrer
how has Missy Elliott inspired junior
career Oh me she's inspired me just to
be a female and break these barriers I
mean I remember there was a time where
people didn't know there was another
female producer outside of Miss Yeley
because that's how male dominated it's
always been and she's just broken so
many barriers from you know singing to
dancing to producing to rapping and just
to see her get her just do to me is the
best thing you ever seen she's a she's
icon legend and what a way to honor the
icon by celebrating her keke palmer is
going to help us play a little game
called finish that Missy lyric not
guessed that lyric we're gonna finish
that's right so we're gonna hear a part
of a famous Missy song and what we have
to do is uh guess the rest of the lyrics
when the music stops yeah got it
I'm ready all right let's do it there we
go all right you guys I'm gonna kind of
moderate this one here's the first one
[Music]
yeah you guys you guys I'm jumping
around on the song the lyrics don't
match my card but you guys are we're
gonna show we do another one
[Music]
Oh III didn't even get on Keegan's hit
with just our rolls-royce yeah
rolls-royce Lamborghini okay huh thing
about your rectum yeah yep about your
rectum I'm a pain
I'm that'd be awesome time yeah exile me
let me give me a shot
where was it common rerun two more
minutes
I know I'm gonna hit when the sound of
the rain hits my window when the rain
hits my window I take an inhale inhale
one more here we go this is it for me
[Applause]
[Music]
Yano y'all pull rope by severing it
bring about steps in a bit clothes get
burnt like toasts bring about bring
about know ah no I know that song is
Ludacris is rap because I know he's got
nominated for the song wasn't flung a
pass okay you know what we do possible
I'm gonna say that was the past anyways
keke palmer thinking make sure to check
out her new film pimp y'all okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]